Sky News has obtained a copy of Harry's
new book due to be published on Tuesday
in it he reveals that he and his brother
William wanted to reopen the
investigation into the death of his
mother Princess Diana believing that
there had been corruption and cover-ups
he says especially the summary
conclusion that our mother's driver was
drunk and as a result that was the only
cause of the accident it was simplistic
and absurd
even if the man had been drinking even
if he had been drunk he wouldn't have
had any problem driving through such a
short tunnel unless Paparazzi were
following him and dazzled him why had
those Paparazzi got off lightly why
weren't they in prison who had sent them
and why weren't those people in jail
either what other reason could there be
apart from corruption and cover-ups
being the order of the day
we agreed on all those questions and
also what we should do next we would
issue a statement asking jointly for the
investigation to be reopened we might
call a press conference those who
decided dissuaded us
Prince Harry also reveals that he and
his brother William asked their father
Charles not to marry Camilla
in the book it says that's why when the
question came Willy and I promised our
father that we would welcome Camilla to
the family the only thing we asked for
in return was that he didn't marry her
you don't need to get married again we
asked him
Prince Harry also admitted in the book
that he killed 25 people during his tour
in Afghanistan
he says this most soldiers don't know
exactly how many kills they have to
their credit
under battle conditions you often fire
indiscriminately however in the age
Apaches and laptops everything I did in
the course of two tours of Duty was
recorded and time stamped
I could always tell exactly how many
enemy combatants I'd killed and it
seemed essential for me not to be afraid
of that figure
among the many things I learned in the
armed forces one of the most important
was to be accountable for my own actions
so my number 25 it was not something
that filled me with satisfaction but I
was not ashamed either naturally I would
have preferred not to have that figure
on my military resume or in my head but
I would also have preferred to live in a
world without the Taliban a world
without War
however he goes on even for a casual
practitioner of wishful thinking like
myself that our realities that cannot be
changed Tour of Duty nearing end around
Christmas 2012.
Sussex also claimed he was attacked by
Prince William during a row about his
wife Megan
he William called me another name then
came at me it all happened so fast so
very fast he grabbed me by the collar
ripping my necklace and he knocked me to
the floor
I landed on the dog's bowl which cracked
under my back the pieces cutting into me
I lay there for a moment dazed then got
to my feet and told him to get out
in an interview with Good Morning
America to promote the book Prince Harry
was quizzed on why he described Prince
William as his arch nemesis
the quote in his book where you refer to
your brother as your beloved brother and
arch nemesis
strong words what did you mean by that
there is always been
this competition
between us weirdly I think it really
plays into always played by the air
spare
joins me now good evening Ashner so well
where to start I mean some extraordinary
Revelations
you really do get
not only that this is a huge Rift which
is ripping not only through the Duke of
Sussex household but also right through
the royal family too and something that
has been going on for years and in his
own words and this is in the Duke of
Sussex Harry's own words he has written
this book you get a sense of that huge
amount of resentment that he has and
touching first of all on the fact that
he wants and it continues to press for
answers on how his mother died saying
that he wanted he and his brother to
open reopen an investigation into those
circumstances in August of 1997 to
discover exactly what led to her death
he says that they were dissuaded from
doing so he refuses to accept the
summary conclusion he says that the
driver had been drinking and that this
was an accident he repeatedly says that
he wanted answers for this and that both
of them wanted answers from this but
that they were advised not to do so you
I mentioned there the resentment and you
you do get a sense of how deep this Rift
between the two brothers really is
speaking about their time eaten together
he describes the fact that Prince
William did not want to be did not want
to know him did not want to um want it
known within the school that they were
brothers he says William told me to
pretend not to know him you don't know
me Harold and I don't know you for the
two previous years he explained to me
Eaton had been his sanctuary and at that
time the fact we studied at the same
school seemed to him a real torture we
then hear about this physical
altercation that happened once Prince
William had allegedly made comments
about Megan describing her as being
difficult abrasive and rude and this was
an altercation that took place at
Nottingham Cottage where the couple was
staying in 2019 and we hear how Prince
William allegedly grabbed Prince Harry
and threw him to the floor
a set again giving a sense of how far
that Rift has gone and how essentially
the Prince Harry had continued to
compare himself to his brother all these
years there's a quote in there talking
about how they shared a bedroom in
Balmoral in describing his brother's
bedroom he said it was luxurious mine
was less luxurious he says I never asked
why I didn't care although I didn't even
need to two years older than me Willy
was the heir well I was the spare those
the words of Prince Harry he said that
slang was often used by my father by my
mother and Grandpa even by grandmother
grandmother the air and the replacement
they would say it without being
judgmental but also without any
ambiguity I was the Shadow the
supporting actor Plan B and we get more
of a sense of what led him to take
cocaine for the first time age 17 he
said he wanted to feel different but it
didn't make him as happy as others
seemed to be
but when talking about the queen consort
Camilla in this this is where there are
big question marks of how the palace's
current silence whether that's able to
stick King Charles has often said that
when it comes to Camilla that for him is
very much a red line that that's not to
be crossed so the fact you've got this
statement essentially from Prince Harry
saying that him and his brother didn't
didn't want
his father tamari Camilla whether Bucky
and Palace or Kensington Palace go on to
comment specifically on that we'll have
to wait and see but so far no comment
from either Palace or Kensington Palace
on any of these allegations now it'll be
interesting to see whether or how they
respond and just one does really wonder
what Harry is trying to achieve by all
this
he says at the beginning of this book
this is his truth and it's in his own
words I don't think many people have
expected it to be just as explosive as
we are seeing it play out not only have
we had the Oprah Winfrey interview and
then the Netflix documentary that came
out followed it and also now this and it
is some 500 pages of some seriously
damaging allegations really peeling back
um that that facade I suppose that that
he seems to think the institution has
and clearly some very deep ingrained
issues that he's had with them for such
a long time when responding to the
racism allegations of course following
the Oprah interview that the couple gave
a Prince William did was very open to
the press and he did say that the royal
family is not a racist family responding
to those allegations the question is
also how much their silence is able to
hold surely surely there will need to be
some some answers given here because
we're not hearing the full story of
course and that's important to know when
you're reading this book too in that
altercation for example we're not
hearing what Prince William allegedly
said to to invoke that reaction but so
many questions to come from this but
also how incredibly sad a lot of these
Revelations are too that this Rift is so
deep that he's willing to say these
things in a very public way and all with
it a book that's not even been released
yet